now we're ready to go back to our actual
exam question um and i will come back to
i will return to desmos to explore this
a bit further but uh let's think about
what these equations can tell me
particularly in part one it says explain
the difference in the domain
of all three paths okay so
let's
all right
so let's explore each of these we'll do
them one at a time okay i might move
this down and use a bit more space up
here okay
now if i just start with this first
parametric equation i really could use
any of them because the question has
told me that all three
parametric equations have the same
cartesian equation i'm just going to
start with the first one because why not
you've got the horizontal component
which i'm going to call x these
equations have no x's and y's but i'm
looking for a cartesian equation so i'm
going to introduce the x's and y's i'm
going to say x is equal to this
horizontal component here you can see
that 2t right there
and then i'm going to say y equals 8 t
cubed so you can see that in this
vertical component over here so what i
want is a relationship between x and y
and you know you've been given a fairly
simple parametric equation here so maybe
you can see right what's the thing
you're going to do
2x in order to turn it into y and the
answer is well 2 turning into an 8 the
relationship there you could say oh i'm
multiplying by 4 but that wouldn't you
know carry along with the the t right t
turning into t cubed well i'm
multiplying it by itself three times
right so i can say um since x cubed
equals two t or cubed which is eight t
cubed which is the thing i'm looking for
that's y right so i've got my cartesian
equation right there i mean when we're
used to y being subject so i'll just
write it like so but that's it that's
all that you're being asked for when
they say find the cartesian equation y
equals x cubed you're done that's it
okay
but then i have to sort of go a bit
further and i have to say well what is
the difference in the domains of these
right when you throw in values of t
what happens to
the values of x and y that you get
well if you just go back to let's go
back to desmos over here right when we
had a look at i'm just going to put the
regular
old
corner there and press play there we go
um as i go from naught to two pi right
you can see i have a spot um or rather i
have a value of a the angle that
corresponds to every single spot on the
unit circle right there's no part of the
unit circle that i can't reach however
if i say for example if i restricted my
angle there would be some parts of the
unit circle i couldn't get to right you
saw me going from naught from not here
to pi like so and you're like oh if i
was only between naught and pi i
wouldn't be able to go
through the entire unit circle i would
only be able to say my um my domain is
still from negative one to one but my
range would only be from zero to one
right so there's this idea here that the
parametric equation and limitations of
the parametric equation will lead to
limitations on the cartesian equation
specifically with regard to domain and
range
now when you have a look back at the
question right there's no domain
restriction um you know sort of
explicitly said like oh t can only be
between here and here but there are some
domain restrictions that are implied for
example let's now have a look at this
second parametric equation right
see this one here even if we just look
at that t cube t squared squared term
rather
when you think about t squared right as
t changes what happens to t squared well
if you have something like t equals zero
that means that t squared will also
equal to zero
t equals one that gives me t squared is
also equal to one t equals two that
gives me t squared equals 4. so i can
get the values in between 0 and 1 or 1
and 4 by choosing values between 0 and 1
1 and 2 for t
however there are some values of t
squared so you know what's going to feed
into the x
of this cartesian equation that you
can't ever reach right it's not because
there's a domain restriction on t but
it's because of the operation you're
applying to t namely you're squaring it
right maybe you're starting to put
together the dots i'm in the real number
world here so if you think about
something like say t equals negative 1
what is that going to map to and the
answer is because you're squaring that's
going to map to 1 which you've already
mapped to already you've already got
something that represents t squared
equals 1
but my point is that i can't ever get
something t squared which will be
negative if i'm still in the real number
world right
no matter what t you throw in there
you'll never get some negative value for
t squared which means you'll never get a
negative value for the x component here
right so noticing that t squared
is greater than or equal to zero
no matter what value
t
takes on within the real number sphere
what that means is that's that x
itself has to be greater than or equal
to 0 because that's what the
that's what the x values come from from
this t squared right so this is a domain
restriction you can see here that is
implied it's not explicit but it's
implied by the particular parametric
equation that you've got your parametric
equation affects the kind of cartesian
values you can get out of it okay now if
x is greater than or equal to zero think
about what the y equals x cubed curve
looks like
you're only going to get positive values
for y as well because i mean we know
what y equals x cubed looked like right
here it is let me just draw it like so
quick and dirty version here
like that
so if i restrict myself to these
positive value or rather these
non-negative values of x i am allowed to
be at x equals 0. you can see which
values can i actually reside i'll use
green since i did that over there
you can see i'm only getting these ones
right and i include the origin there
here is my restriction on x is greater
than or equal to zero which also implies
that y is going to be greater than or
equal to zero because you can see that's
what the cubic curve does okay
so um you can see here i'm now starting
to get at the idea that there is
different um there are different parts
of the path that i can get onto based on
the parametric equation
so i actually kind of skipped over with
the first equation here um 2t
and 8t cubed i mean when you see this is
part of why i used it to begin with
there are actually no restrictions there
any value of
x and y can be obtained by choosing an
appropriate value for t so what i would
say is for r1
i did that in blue um x can take on all
real values you can always find if
there's a particular x you want you can
always find a t that will get it to you
there you just have to halve
your value of x and you'll get your
value of t and in the same way y has no
restrictions on it either
but what we've just noticed is that for
r2 that's not the case because you're
squaring
and because this is just something cubed
then squared that's y to the s that's t
to the sixth that means that you're also
going to get these non-negative values
for y okay and then lastly we go to r3
now you're not squaring so there's not
going to be restrictions on your sign
here um you can still get negative
values out of this if i put in a
negative value of t
in here you will get a negative value of
x but there is a value of t that you
cannot substitute into either of these
different
parametric forms again it's not explicit
it's just implied in the equation we can
never divide through by zero that's not
defined right so therefore t can't equal
zero you can go anywhere else but you
can't reside z um right at the origin so
i'm going to say here
let's just complete that oops this is
supposed to be green wasn't it
okay let's just fix that up so what am i
getting here it's the fact that these
these denominators here right you can't
ever substitute t into those
denominators so i'm going to say
let's do this back in purple so it's all
together r three
you can say all real values except for x
equals 0 but i think it's just as
succinct to say
x is less than 0 or
x is greater than 0 and alongside that y
is less than 0 or y is greater than zero
x equals zero y equals zero that's the
only part that breaks it okay
all right so that that is part one
that's the differences in the domain of
these two parametric equations when we
come back to the exam paper if you
recall part two asks us to push in a
little further it says explain the
direction of travel
of a point p
on the path r2 okay so it's this one
here right r2 was this one in the middle
so um as t increases from negative
infinity to infinity what is happening
to
um point p as it moves along r2 so
as promised i'm going to go back to
desmos for this one right this is me
getting at this idea of well if i hit
play here right well let's put that
label back on right you can see the
normal parametric equations for
the unit circle they move anti-clockwise
right
but this alternate way if i've swapped
cos and sine it's moving clockwise
anti-clockwise and clockwise the
language of that only makes sense on
circles of course
we are looking at y equals x cubed for
our question so what's that going to
mean for each of them okay
let me hit pause on that before we
explore desmos let's just think um
algebraically because you can't bring
decimals into the exam with you at least
not yet let's think algebraically about
what's going on here right as t
increases from negative infinity to
infinity what's going on right
well when you put in some really large
negative number into here you square it
right so your x value is going to become
um once it's even though it's negative
it gets you know you just the sign
disappears it just becomes positive and
you're going to have some very large x
value right some negative
large value like say negative a million
why am i doing that in green it should
be sorry in blue it should be green
let's go back over that
negative a thousand when you square it
you get positive
a million right and then of course when
you
raise it to the power of 6 it's even
larger okay now as you bring that value
down if i go to say negative 10
because i'm going from negative infinity
towards infinity so my values are
increasing that's just going to give you
positive 100 right so even that's still
enormous i'm coming closer to the origin
right i started at a million and now i'm
returning to the origin but then what
happens is as i pass through zero and
then to the positive numbers i start to
move away from the origin again right
because it starts going back through 100
and then a million and then etc etc
right so you can see what's going on in
fact we can have a look at all of the
different um
parametric equations even though this
particular one is only asking us about
r2
there we go put that away
if we move that out by accident there we
go that's better here's the exam
question so y equals x cubed there's our
curve there
let's just think about what's happening
to
t squared t to the 6 that's our r2
equation when i hit play right can you
see what's going on here
this is that behavior we were describing
before right from the negatives you
start over on huge positive values but
then as you get towards 0 you hit the
origin and then you rebound right and
that's kind of what a quadratic is doing
it's coming down towards the origin and
then it's going back up but this time
what we're sort of moving along is this
path here
along the y equals x cubed path and like
we predicted in part one there's no
value of t that will let you get down
into the negative part for r2 right
while we're animating this and i have
them here you can see if i just look at
2t 8t cubed it's just moving in a linear
fashion from left to right because my
values of t are going from left to right
and when you double them it's just doing
that motion just faster right and lastly
just for interest even though we weren't
asked about it here comes r3 this is a
weird one right what's going on here
when you go along we're going backwards
right because when you have a value of t
and you put in the denominator as t
increases
the value of one over t decreases so
that's why you're moving from right to
left but then you might notice there's
this hole in the middle there right
what's going on there and the answer is
it's because my values of t here and
they go from negative 1.5 to 1.5
when i try and get closer you can see
bam i need small or rather larger values
of t to get closer to the origin right
so for example if i just hit pause on
that
and i said okay i'm willing to go say
negative 15
to 15. now if i press play again
you can see i get closer there you go i
get as close as 1 on 15 but then
i still can't get there i will never get
to 0 because as we discussed in part 1
the domain of this 1 over t 1 over t
cubed restricts us from doing that you
can never divide by 0.
so um you know sorry no matter how get
big t gets you'll never actually reach
zero because you need you'd need
infinity on that denominator in order to
reach this so that's why you can see it
doesn't quite get there and there's a
discontinuity so just returning back
this is the actual one we're interested
in it uh it's going too fast now because
i'm going 10 times quicker let's put
that decimal point back 1.5
1.5 there we go
so i need to use language to describe
this right so what i would say is i'm
starting
in the top right at x equals positive
infinity i return to the origin and then
when x passes when t rather passes 0 i
start increasing again and going to the
right so i would write that in a form i
guess a bit like this
this is part two
part two
when
t increases
or rather when t begins
at um negative infinity where is the
where am i on the cartesian equation on
the cartesian graph i'm all the way off
in the top right right so um the
cartesian
or rather the point p i should say the
point p
is at the top right
of the cartesian path
which is y equals x cubed
as t approaches
0 right so this is
you know t getting smaller and smaller
in terms of magnitude
p
approaches
the origin
and then once it t
passes
0 and approaches
infinity
p returns
you can see it going sort of rebounding
back into the top right returns
to the top right
and that's it you can see how this is a
different use of the parametric
equations that you've not seen before
that we're comparing different
parametric equations that give you the
same cartesian equation but now you can
see the difference between each of them
and it's a an interesting exploration of
domain and range and also direction um
that even relates to how subsets of the
complex plane work so that's part of why
you can see this in the extension 2
course